MURAT: Dam-da-dam-daaa! Dam-da-dam-daaa!
Oh, die Wurst! Sally!
Wasser! Sally!
SALLY: Murat.
MURAT: Feuer! Sally!
Murats 5 Minuten!
SALLY: Murat, ernschthaft?!
MURAT: Herzlich willkommen zu Murats 5 Minuten.
Heute mache ich etwas richtig Geniales.
Wird wieder ein No-Bake Cake
- klar, ihr habt es nicht anders von mir erwartet.
Und zwar ein Blueberry Lemon Cake.
Ja, mach ich. Genau.
Ich habe heut wieder Hilfe bei mir.
Ich mache es heute nicht alleine.
Der Verfassungsschutz kennt ihn.
Das BKA kennt ihn.
Attila Hildmanns Cousin:
Güni! Jawoll, Güni ist heute da und hilft mir.
Meine Frau ist übrigens nicht da.
Warum ich sie nicht da?
GÜNI: Sie hat kapiert, wie blöd du bist.
Sie ist ab.
Sie kommt auch nicht mehr zurück, hat sie gesagt.
MURAT: Ja. Okay, gut.
GÜNI: Du musst mit mir vorliebnehmen.
MURAT: Ja leider.
Meine Frau ist gerade in Berlin,
macht gerade…
GÜNI: Was?
MURAT: Ja, sie ist in Berlin.
Ja, jetzt gerade.
Also heute ist sie in Berlin
und macht die Synchronisation für Baby Boss.
Kennst du?
GÜNI: Baby was?
MURAT: Baby Boss.
Das ist so ein Kinderfilm, so mit Kindern… [Doing]
Zeichentrick.
Genau, das macht sie.
GÜNI: Bist du Baby Boss?
MURAT: Ich bin Baby Boss, ja.
So auf jeden Fall…
Du warst ja auch schon Synchronsprecher für Stummfilme.
Hab ich recht? [Güni bejaht] Genau.
GÜNI: Sag mal, für wie blöd hältst du mich?
MURAT: Viel, viel! So.
Aua! So…
Und deswegen machen wir einen richtig cooel Kuchen.
Ganz, ganz easy gemach, saumäßig schnell.
Es bekommt wirklich jeder hin.
Deswegen ist heute auch der Güni da,
um euch dann auch wirklich zu zeigen,
dass es wirklich jeder hinbekommt.
Fangen wir oder? Fangen wir mit den Zutaten an.
Genau.
Für den Boden brauchen wir ganz, ganz einfache Sachen.
250 g Schokokekse, 50 g Butterkekse und 75 g Butter.
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich dauernd Leibniz Butterkekse habe.
Das sind übrigens… Ist keine Produktplatzierung!
Ihr könnt die auch vom Lidl holen.
Könnt ihr auch machen.
Die sind nun echt mit 52 Zähnen.
Ja, echte Zähne.
Kennst du dich nicht mehr aus, habe ich recht?
[Beide lachen]
GÜNI: Du aber auch gleich nicht mehr. [Beide lachen]
[Country.Musik]
MURAT: Okay, fangen wir ganz einfach an,
und zwar, Güni, schmilzt du die 75 g Butter okay?
Auf dem auf dem Herd.
Während du das machst, zerkleinere ich die Kekse, okay?
Und zwar haben wir hier wieder den SPEEDWING 250 pro von Gefu.
Damit zerkleinere ich die Kekse.
Wie gesagt, ich zerkleinere die Kekse mit dem SPEEDWING von Gefu.
Genau, wenn ihr das nicht habt, könnt ihr auch Ding nehmen.
Was kann man noch nehmen?
GÜNI: Was?
MURAT: Wie kann man Kekse noch zerkleinern,
wenn man keinen SPEEDWING hat?
GÜNI: Mit einem Mörser.
MURAT: Ja genau, mit einem Mörser.
Mit einem Mörser könnt ihr das machen.
Einfach die Kekse rein - zack!
[Doing] Ich habe mich übrigens verletzt,
also am Finger meine ich.
Warte, nicht zu voll machen! Ganz, ganz wichtig.
Sonst blockiert er.
Ich habe keine Kraft. Ohne Finger geht's nicht.
Ich mache es mit der anderen Hand.
Geht auch nicht…
Was habe ich falsch gemacht?
Ah, ich habe es blockiert.
Ah, die sind verklemmt.
Stimmt. Tut mir leid. Tut mir leid.
Kann ja mal passieren.
GÜNI: So blöd kann man doch gar nicht sein.
MURAT: Doch, so blöd kann man wirklich sein.
Du siehst es doch, oder?
GÜNI: Ja, aber ich bin verblüfft.
MURAT: Verblüfft, ja? So, mache mal kurz!
GÜNI: Warte!
MURAT: Ich kann es halt nicht, weil meine Hand weh tut.
GÜNI: Hast du geweint? [Murat bejaht]
MURAT: So, genau.
Dein Latissimus ist…
Latissimus… durchtrainiert, gell? [Güni bejaht]
Merkst du es?
GÜNI: Beim Mähen, gell? Irgendwann wird es Mehl.
MURAT: So.
Zack!
Und jetzt darfst du einen Fehler nicht machen, Güni.
Ich weiß, dass du diesen Fehler gemacht hättest.
[Doing] Ich mache wieder den gleichen Fehler wie vorhin.
So, Keks wieder raus.
So, einmal zack!
Die anderen Butterkeksen nehme ich nachher nur für oben,
für die Schicht.
GÜNI: Die sind auch Vollkorn, oder? [Murat bejaht] Hafer…
MURAT: Du kannst auch jeden Keks nehmen, worauf du Bock hast.
Du kannst jeden Keks nehmen, auf den du Lust hast.
Gibt es einen Keks, den du am liebsten magst?
Gibt es einen Lieblingskeks von dir?
Magst du irgendwelche Kekse besonders?
GÜNI: Murat Kekse.
MURAT: Ja… So!
Wahnsinn, oder? Ist doch nicht normal, was für eine Kraft ich habe.
GÜNI: Ja, das ist…
So langsam bekomme ich Angst.
MURAT: Und das Ding kommt aus dem Sauerland, wollte ich sagen.
So, das war's!
GÜNI: Warst du mal Ruderer?
MURAT: Ja, ist dir das aufgefallen?
GÜNI: Ja, dieser Körper…
MURAT: Und zwar war ich in der Staffel 72 in Montréal. [Güni lacht]
Das wolltest du doch hören, oder? Jetzt bist du doch glücklich!
Das hast du wieder herausgefordert.
GÜNI: Was höre ich da? Wo… [Lacht]
MURAT: Der Wahnsinn, du!
GÜNI: Das gibt's doch gar nicht. Staffel…
MURAT: Okay. Hast du schon zusammen…
GÜNI: Was war das? 72 in Montréal? [Murat stimmt zu]
Warst du da überhaupt schon auf der Welt?
MURAT: Ja.
GÜNI: Nein.
MURAT: Doch.
GÜNI: Gott!
MURAT: Jetzt haben wir die Kekse zusammengemischt.
Du machst die Butter. Genau.
Und jetzt tust du mir einen Gefallen, Güni.
GÜNI: Ich kann ja auch alles alleine machen.
MURAT: Jetzt pass auf!
Wenn die Butter geschmolzen ist,
tust du sie einfach hier rein und dann umrühren.
Es ist ein Backlöffel.
Da kann man nämlich durchschauen. Genau.
Das machst du mit einem Backlöffel, okay?
Während du das machst, tue ich in der Zwischen-scheit… zwei.
In der Zwischen… [Güni lacht]
Während du das machst…
GÜNI: In der Zwischenzeit…
MURAT: Zwischenzeit! Entschuldigung.
Warum bist du immer so aggressiv?
GÜNI: Nein.
MURAT: Doch, du kommst wie so eine Krähe?
Als würdest du gleich auf mich springen.
So, okay. Während du das machst, hole ich schon mal die Backform.
So, dann haben wir hier das Premium-Backblech.
Auf dieses Premium-Backblech kommt eine Dauerbackfolie.
So, die könnt ihr öfter benutzen, also auf Dauer
- deswegen Dauerbackfolie.
Hast du kapiert?
GÜNI: Nein, nicht ganz.
MURAT: So, dann stellen wir den Tortenring auf 20 cm ein,
stellen ihn einfach drauf.
Ist sie schon geschmolzen?
GÜNI: Noch nicht, gleich!
MURAT: Aber schon krass, dass ich dir zutraue,
dass du die Butter zum Schmelzen bringst, gell?
Ich finde, das ist echt der Wahnsinn.
So, einfach rein Günni.
[Musik]
Wenn ich dich so anschaue,
kennst du dich mit gesunder Ernährung nicht so gut aus, gell?
Kann das sein, dass das ein bisschen dein blinder Fleck ist?
GÜNI: Ich bin froh, dass du so auf deine Linie achtest.
MURAT: Kann es sein, dass…
GÜNI: Ich habe gestern eine Tiersendung gesehen.
Da war ein japanischer Kugelfisch dabei.
Kennst du den?
MURAT: Ja. Ich finde immer seine Vergleiche richtig geil.
Es erzählt mir immer jeden Tag solche Geschichten.
GÜNI: Nein.
MURAT: Doch, hör auf, Fernseher zu gucken.
Der guckt den ganzen Tag nur Fernsehen.
GÜNI: Weißt du, was er macht, wenn Gefahr droht?
Er bläht sich auf.
Du brauchst keine Angst zu haben. Ich mach' dir nichts.
[Beide lachen]
MURAT: Das tut mir voll leid.
Diese Sendung ist für Kinder ab 6 Jahren geeignet, aber maximal bis 10.
Danach ist alles raus.
GÜNI: Was ist das? Für Hamburger?
MURAT: Ja, und zwar…
Das ist der King Size Classic 200 G von Gefu.
Und zwar ist das ein Keramik Patty.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, dieses Patty haben wir vielleicht
einmal wirklich für Hamburger benutzt.
Aber ansonsten nehmen wir sie wirklich nur für No-bake Kuchen.
Ist ein ganz cooles Tool!
So, jetzt machen wir Folgendes, GÜNI:
Wir legen diesen Keksteige hier auf den Boden,
und zwar schnell, bevor er abkühlt.
Also hier rein.
[Musik]
So. Kannst du das machen? Mein Finger tut voll weh.
Wirklich, wirklich echt…
Ich hab echt Schmerzen. Das ist immer…
Bei mir hat sich, glaube ich, irgendwie…
Ich habe irgendeine Wunde gehabt.
Die hat sich dann entzündet.
Das tut echt richtig weh. Das sind echt starke Schmerzen. [Güni lacht]
Warum lachst du?
GÜNI: Ich habe, wenn ich neben dir stehe,
ganz starke Schmerzen in den Augen, ehrlich!
[Musik]
MURAT: Ich hab doch gesagt, den Rand nach oben machen.
GÜNI: Nein, das muss das so.
MURAT: Jetzt hast du es runtergedrückt!
GÜNI: Sieht doch viel besser aus!
Guck!
MURAT: Du hast auch Pech beim Denken, gell?
Richtig Pech, du bist so ein Unglücksvogel.
Das gibt's doch gar nicht!
GÜNI: Ehrlich? [Murat bejaht]
MURAT: Okay. Egal, dann drück ihn runter - nicht schlimm!
GÜNI: Schön verdichtet.
MURAT: Schön verdichtet.
Richtig gut.
GÜNI: Das ist jetzt wie ein Hartkeks.
MURAT: Genau, wie ein harter Keks.
Genau. Ja, du bist so ein… Ich bin so…
Ich bin eigentlich ein harter Keks…
GÜNI: Nein!
MURAT: Und du bist so ein schöner Butterkeks.
Kann das sein? [Yiha]
GÜNI: Ich sage es nicht.
MURAT: Ein Scherzkeks?
GÜNI: Nein, fängt mit F an! [Spannungsvolle Melodie]
MURAT: Ein fetter Keks?
GÜNI: Nein, nein!
Nein, ein fauler Keks!
MURAT: Fauler Keks. Okay, alles klar.
So, jetzt haben wir das hier fertig
und kühlen es für ungefähr für 30 Min. im Kühlschrank.
GÜNI: Guck mal, wie schön das ist.
MURAT: Echt cool, sieht echt toll aus!
Du bist richtig talentiert, Keksboden auszustechen.
Echt toll!
[Uhr]
So, der Keksboden ist jetzt abgekühlt.
Richtig, Güni? Ist er kühl?
Ja, so! Kühl…
Läuft nichts.
So, auf jeden Fall haben wir jetzt den Keksboden.
Jetzt machen wir die coole Pudding-Creme.
Die kommt wirklich auf den Keksboden drauf.
Dazu nehmen wir einen Topf und erhitzen ihn schon einmal ein bisschen.
Dann brauchen wir 500 g Milch, 2 Eigelb von glücklichen Hühnern,
45 g Stärke, 40 g Zucker und 1 Zitrone.
Genau, eine Bio Zitrone. Ganz, ganz wichtig.
Davon brauchen wir nämlich den Abrieb
und die Hälfte der Zitrone nachher für den Pudding.
GÜNI: Saft!
MURAT: Saft, genau!
Dann nehmen wir die 500 g Milch
und geben nur ein bisschen in den Topf rein.
So…
Normalerweise sieht es bei meiner Frau professionell aus,
aber ich bin nicht professionell.
Wollte ich nur einmal sagen.
So, dann reiben wir die Zitronenschale in die Milch.
Ja, Abrieb!
Ich kann mich noch erinnern,
du hast mich mal früher Zitronenschüttler genannt.
Kann das sein?
Doch, doch, doch, ich kann mich noch erinnern.
Du hast mich mal Zitronenschütter genannt.
Ich wollte es nur mal in der Öffentlichkeit sagen.
Doch, doch, doch, doch.
GÜNI: Du täuschst dich, das war ich nicht.
Doch ehrlich.
MURAT: Hütchenspieler und Zitronensüttler hast du mich genannt.
Die Hälfte der Zitrone pressen wir jetzt hier rein.
Aua! Mir tut voll der Finger weh. Kannst du mir helfen?
Grillengeräusche
GÜNI: Kannst du mal meine Mama anrufen?
[Beide lachen]
MURAT: Du bist so blöd.
Mein Gott, eh!
GÜNI: Können wir…
MURAT: Wo ist meine Frau nochmal?
GÜNI: Ab in Berlin. Sie kommt auch nicht mehr!
MURAT: Sie hat es kapiert, gell? [Güni stimmt zu]
Sie hat es kapiert.
So, jetzt tun wir hier… Bitte schön.
Und ganz wichtig: die Zitrone nicht wegschmeißen.
Der Güni würde sie jetzt wegschmeißen,
weil der Güni normalerweise auch Güni-kologe ist.
Diese Zitrone hier vorne beim Spülfach in die Spülmaschine rein!
Ist nämlich ein toller Reinigungsverstärker
und natürlich macht es auch Kalkflecken weg.
Das könnt ihr 2-3 Spülgänge drin lassen.
GÜNI: Hast du schon mal überlegt, in Zitronensaft zu baden?
MURAT: Nein, warum?
GÜNI: Es macht sauber und…
MURAT: So. Auf jeden Fall…
Dann nehmen wir die Eier dazu
und rühren sie ein.
Wie gesagt, auf Stufe 2.
Es muss nur warm werden.
Das ist das Wichtige: nur warm werden!
Ist es warm?
GÜNI: Sonst grillt nämlich das Ei, gell?
MURAT: Genau. Du bist intelligent.
Du siehst gar nicht so intelligent aus, aber du bist es.
GÜNI: Du unterschätzt mich.
MURAT: So, die Eier rein.
Dann gibst du mir gerade die Stärke, Güni.
GÜNI: Nicht noch Milch?
MURAT: Nee, nee, nee, die Milch kommt erst zum Schluss rein.
Nicht alles, weißt du?
Sonst verklumpt es.
Weil…
Du verstehst das nicht. Das ist Chemie.
Chemie!
GÜNI: Chemie…
MURAT: Chemie…
Kannst du mir das… Warte kurz!
Danke schön.
Geht schon!
So, jetzt gibst du mir den Zucker, Güni.
GÜNI: Bin ich dein… ?
MURAT: Ach so.
GÜNI: Helfer?
MURAT: Ich meine, mache doch du!
GÜNI: Nein! Mach du.
Du hast die Technik.
MURAT: Mir tut aber voll der Finger weh, wirklich!
GÜNI: Soll ich deine Mama anrufen?
MURAT: Warum muss ich… Warum müssen wir zusammen kochen?
Ich verstehe es nicht.
GÜNI: Ich wollte auch lieber mit der Sally kochen.
MURAT: Ja, das glaub ich dir.
GÜNI: Das ist ein viel schönerer Anblick als du.
MURAT: Ach so. Boah, Wahnsinn!
GÜNI: Was machst du denn?
MURAT: Den Zucker noch rein. So.
Jetzt schön ein bisschen warmwerden lassen.
Jetzt geben wir noch den Rest rein.
[Bling]
GÜNI: Du warst wie der Prinz - wie der Geissen, der Geiss…
Der Robert Geiss hat auch immer so…
MURAT: Aus dem Weg, Geringverdiener! Aus dem Weg, Geringverdiener!
Das sagt er doch immer.
Aus dem Weg, ihr Geringverdiener!
So, nebenher sauber machen,
weil ich es so von meinem Meister gelernt habe.
So, wie der Arbeitsplatz ist, so schafft man auch,
sagt man bei uns im Schwabenländle.
GÜNI: So ist man auch!
MURAT: Nein, so, wie man schafft, so ist man auch.
GÜNI: Dann müsstest du…
MURAT: eine Maschine sein!
[Güni lacht]
Du hast aber auch schon ganz schön viel geschafft. Kann das sein?
GÜNI: Ja, ich habe schon viel geschafft.
MURAT: So, und jetzt erst, wenn die ganze Milch drin ist
und alles schön nicht mehr klumpt, dann aufkochen.
[Musik]
[Güni lacht]
GÜNI: Guck mal, guck mal!
MURAT: Ich finde, manchmal bist du echt…
Ich gucke mir abends immer die Filme mit dir an
und habe dann immer ein schlechtes Gefühl.
Weißt du das?
GÜNI: Weinst du dann?
MURAT: Ja, ich weine dann unter der Dusch. [Traurige Melodie]
Doch, so geht es mir dann.
Mal bist du echt gemein, ohne Witz!
GÜNI: Ach ja…
MURAT: Also liebe Kinder, wenn ihr jetzt gerade schaut…
Die Männer lachen sie wahrscheinlich gerade schief.
Die Frauen sagen: Oh Gott, das hat er nicht gesagt.
Und die Kinder sagen: Ich verstehe es nicht, warum er so ist.
[Emotionale Melodie] Und er ist eigentlich nicht böse.
Muss man ganz, ganz ehrlich sagen.
Er ist ein bisschen beschränkt in seiner Wahrnehmung
und in seinem Wissen,
aber er ist kein böser Mensch und wir sind auch Freunde,
vor der Kamera. [Güni lacht]
So, schön aufkochen.
Jetzt ist es wichtig, dass diese Creme,
dieser Pudding wirklich wie ein Pudding wird.
Also wie z.B. Flexkleber,
wenn ihr die Fliesen an die Wand haut - so ähnlich.
So als Beispiel.
GÜNI: Hast du schon mal Fliesen an die Wand gehauen?
MURAT: Und immer rühren, rühren, rühren.
Ich finde es voll krass, dass ich wieder arbeiten muss.
Kennst du das vom Bau?
Der Deutsche schaut zu, der Türke arbeitet.
Hab ich recht?
[Güni räuspert]
So, jetzt bin ich fertig.
Sieht nachher wirklich wie ein richtiger Pudding aus.
Seht ihr das? Richtig schön.
Und jetzt müsst ihr auch gar nicht abkühlen lassen.
Also jetzt sofort kann er auf den Keksteige drauf
und wird dann richtig schön fest.
So, jetzt geben wir das da rein.
Pass auf, ich hebe ihn und du schüttest ihn dann rein.
Ich weiß nicht, wie meine Frau das alleine macht.
GÜNI: Sie ist geschickter als du.
Aber da fehlt ja nicht viel.
Also da braucht man nicht viel.
MURAT: Boah, ich mache gleich…
GÜNI: Tut dein Finger weh?
MURAT: Ich schwitze gerade.
GÜNI: Nein, ob dein Finger weh tut?
MURAT: Ja, der tut richtig weh.
Das gefällt dir, gell?
Gestern kam es übrigens in der Zeitung:
Da ist einer beim Puddingauskratzen gestorben,
weil er eingeschlafen ist.
GÜNI: Fertig!
MURAT: Fertig? Aber da ist noch etwas. Komm, da ist noch der Rest.
Mein Gott, Güni! Sei doch ein bisschen sparsamer.
Weißt du, wenn du daheim wärst, wärst du richtig sparsam.
Aber da du den Pudding nicht bezahlt hast, juckt dich das gar nicht.
GÜNI: Du hast recht.
MURAT: So, jetzt ist es ganz wichtig.
Dafür hat man jetzt wirklich die abgewinkelte Tortenpalette.
GÜNI: Mach erst einmal sauber.
MURAT: Genau, so…
So, jetzt einfach ansetzen und jetzt.
Guck mal, wie ich das mache…
Ich bin wie Vivaldi.
Guck mal!
GÜNI: Wer war Vivaldi? Ein Komponist, oder?
MURAT: Er war ein italienischer Komponist.
Er lebte von 1820 bis 1897 und der hat auch die…
Kennst du das Stück „Ode an die Freude"?
GÜNI: Was?
MURAT: Ja! Du kennst dich mit klassischer Musik nicht so aus.
Brahms, Tschaikowsky - kennst du dich nicht aus?
GÜNI: Aber du, gell?
MURAT: Ja! Wie viele Symphonien hat Mozart komponiert?
Ich meine Beethoven, Tschuldigung!
6, denn die 7. ist verloren gegangen.
Das weißt du alles gar nicht.
Kann es sein, dass du so einen geringen Allgemeinbildungs-Ding hast?
Das ist Wahnsinn. Das ist ja…
GÜNI: Haben sie dich auch verloren?
Wie viele Geschwister hast du? 6.
Du bist verloren, weil du zu dick warst.
[Beide lachen]
[Musik]
MURAT: Jetzt haben wir noch Blaubeeren.
Es ist gerade Saison - kriegt ihr momentan überall.
Einfach die Blaubeeren…
GÜNI: [Mit lauterer Stimmer] Nein!
MURAT: Warum denn?
GÜNI: Nicht mit deinen Fingern!
Nein, nein!
MURAT: Ja… Mein Gott.
[Musik]
So, perfekt!
GÜNI: Ein bisschen andrücken!
MURAT: Ein bisschen andrücken, genau.
So, und jetzt 1 Stunde kühlen!
GÜNI: Mit diesem hier?
MURAT: Genau, einfach so in den Kühlschrank.
1 Stunde kühlen und warten, was dann passiert.
In der Zwischenzeit räumen der Güni und ich auf.
Mal sehen, wer es überlebt.
Wir sehen uns in einer Stunde wieder.
[Uhr]
Also, jetzt geht's um die 3. Schicht.
[Singt] ♪ Ey DJ, bring den Beat zurück ♪
♪ Mach keine Faxen ♪
♪ Der ganze Club spielt verrückt ♪
Nein…
♪ Der ganze Club brennt. ♪.
Genau.
Kennt du das? Kennst du nicht?
Du warst noch nie in einemClub. Hab ich recht?
GÜNI: Aber du auch nicht. [Lacht]
MURAT: Ich bin reingekommen. Du lachst jetzt.
Du findest das lustig. Verstehst du, was ich meine?
Es ist echt immer so:
GÜNI: Ich meinte, dass sie Leute wie dich draußen abgewiesen haben.
MURAT: Genau. Es war echt so, dass ich nie in den Club reingekommen bin.
Das muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Das war früher echt schlimm.
Wirklich. Für die anderen nicht, aber für mich schon.
GÜNI: Ist das jetzt noch so ein Trauma?
MURAT: Ja, es ist echt noch ein Trauma.
Und zwar bin ich einfach noch rausgekommen,
weil ich dunkelhäutig bin.
Ehrlich, ohne Spaß!
Ich konnte besser Deutsch sprechen als der Türsteher,
bin aber nicht reingekommen.
Es war eine riesenlange Schlange, etwa 30 Meter,
und der Türsteher hockt da und sagt:
Der Typ nach 30 Metern raus, geh nach Hause!
Das war wirklich so!
Aber der Türsteher war selber immer ein Türke,
bber bin nie reingekommen.
GÜNI: Ein Landsmann?
MURAT: Ja, das war echt so.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es heute immer noch so ist, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Ich war dann der Typ, der dann draußen die Parkplätze saubergemacht hat.
GÜNI: Ja, probiere doch einmal.
MURAT: Ich glaube, heute würde ich reinkommen. [Güni stimmt nicht zu]
Nicht?
Auch nicht? [Güni lacht]
Egal jetzt.
GÜNI: Ich will dir keine Hoffnungen machen.
MURAT: Ach so, okay. Alles klar!
Aber du warst…
Du warst einer der Typen, die draußen…
GÜNI: Ich war in allen Clubs.
MURAT: Die draußen am Fenster saßen und die Finger auf mich zeigten:
Guck dir mal den Typ an!
GÜNI: Der da draußen.
Guck mal, der muss wieder heimgehen, der arme Kerl.
[Beide lachen]
MURAT: Ist leider so gewesen. Egal!
Anderes Thema. Tut mir leid, nicht ablenken!
So, die 3 Schicht.
Und zwar brauchen wir für die 3. Schicht
[Lacht]
Also für die 3. Schicht brauchen wir 500 g Magerquark,
40 g Puderzucker, 1 TL Vanilleextrakt, 1/2 Zitrone,
also die Hälfte der anderen Zitrone von vorhin,
6 TL San-apart
und für die Quarksahne brauchen wir 40 g Sahne
und 4 TL San-apart.
Dann Nehmen wir den Quark.
So, die 500 g Quark kannst hier hineingeben.
Genau.
Das ist gestern in der Zeitung gekommen:
Da ist jemand beim Quarkauffüllen
eingeschlafen und gestorben. [Güni lacht]
Hast du einen Schlaganfall?
Du bekommst gleich einen Schlaganfall!
Ja, ich finde, ich darf echt…
GÜNI: Sei jetzt einfach mal ruhig.
MURAT: Bitte! Wenn jetzt kleine Kinder dabei sind:
Es ist nicht böse gemeint, wirklich!
Er ist einfach so. Man kann nichts dafür.
So, jetzt den Zucker rein.
GÜNI: Lass doch mal deine Finger da raus!
MURAT: Dann haben wir 1 TL Vanilleextrakt.
Zack, zack, zack!
Davon kannst du nicht genug bekommen - 2 TL!
Der Günni presst jetzt noch den Zitronensaft aus.
Press doch!
GÜNI: Ich würde dich gerne auspresssen!
MURAT: Ich würde dich auch gerne mal auspressen!
Okay, jetzt lassen wir es mal bei Stufe 2 laufen.
So. Aha.
Was „aha"?
Eins, zwei - jetzt! [Küchenmaschine]
Wahnsinn, oder? Ich hab's schon richtig drauf.
Du musst schon gewitzt.
Ich bin schon gewitzt, muss ich sagen.
Dann nimm mal den Rührbesen!
GÜNI: Du hast keinen Rührbesen.
MURAT: Jetzt tun wir San-apart rein.
Okay. Langsam.
Wir hatten mal so eine Einschütthilfe,
aber ich weiß nicht, wo sie ist.
Jetzt geben wir die Milch mit rein.
GÜNI: Das ist Sahne! [Murat stimmt zu]
MURAT: Entschuldigung. Dann geben wir die Sahne mit rein.
Langsam. Langsam. Langsam.
So, und jetzt das restliche San-apart.
Und jetzt müsst ihr richtig aufpassen.
Es darf nicht zu lange geschlagen werden,
weil sonst wird es zu Butter.
Jetzt mache ich es aus - Achtung! Wahnsinn!
Ich habe sie ausgemacht.
Guck mal, du merkst daran, dass das Ding fertig ist…
GÜNI: Dass es fertig ist.
MURAT: Dass es fertig ist. [Güni lacht]
Hast du Angst?
GÜNI: Vor dir? Nein!
MURAT: Du hast keine Angst?
GÜNI: Nein.
MURAT: Okay, dann machen wir jetzt einen Test.
Okay? Pass auf!
GÜNI: Was machst du denn?
MURAT: Meine Frau hatte mal so einen Schaber.
Kennst du den Schaber, womit man die Sahne abziehen kann? [Güni verneint]
Hol doch mal den Schaber!
Der hat doch solche Dinger dran.
GÜNI: Was willst du denn mit den 3 Krümeln?
Mach das doch so! Geh mal weg!
Guck mal, jetzt ist alles weg. Passt!
Du Schaber, du!
So, jetzt hier rein?
MURAT: Ah, jetzt habe ich die Dinger abgelegt.
GÜNI: Was hast du? Abgelegt? [Murat stimmt zu]
Nimm neue!
MURAT: Warte kurz!
GÜNI: Nein, das können wir nicht mehr nehmen.
MURAT: Was jetzt?
GÜNI: Dann musst du erst einmal unter kochendes Wasser halten.
MURAT: Ach du bist so blöd!
So, ihr seht, ihr merkt…
GÜNI: „Abgelegt". Hier, nimm den kleinen!
MURAT: Ja. Okay.
Ihr merkt, dass das Ding wirklich hart geworden ist,
indem ihr das hier macht.
Ha!
Hast du Angst gekriegt?
GÜNI: Gott, wenn du das so runterläuft!
MURAT: Du würdest dich voll freuen. Ohne Witz!
GÜNI: Bite! Wenn es einen Gott gibt, wenn es einen Gott gibt…
MURAT: Nein!
Seht ihr das?
Und das ist auch der Grund,
warum die Leute beim Fußball in der Champions League das Ding hochheben,
weil da Sahne drin ist.
Genau deswegen machen die das!
GÜNI: Ach Gott!
MURAT: Merkst du das?
GÜNI: Oh Gott, das wäre zu schön.
MURAT: So, jetzt nehmen wir… Jetzt nehmen wir…
GÜNI: Ich wollte nicht mehr leben.
MURAT: Jetzt können wir es reintun, gell?
Willst du es machen oder soll ich?
GÜNI: Nein, mach du!
MURAT: Nein, mach du das!
GÜNI: Mach's!
MURAT: Nein, komm! Mach du!
GÜNI: Du hast so schöne, kurze Arme.
Du kannst es schön anwinkeln.
MURAT: So. Mach du das!
Ich will das nicht mehr machen.
So, jetzt habe ich keine Lust mehr, nachdem du mich beleidigt hast.
GÜNI: Nein!
MURAT: Doch!
Weißt du, woran du mich erinnerst?
Kennst du den Film „Ab durch die Hecke"?
GÜNI: Nein.
MURAT: Da ist dieses Faultier und ist doch Beamter.
[Spricht sehr langsam] Haallooooooo! [Güni lacht]
Was kann ich für Sie tuuuuun?
GÜNI: Kann ich Homeoffice machen?
MURAT: Ja?
GÜNI: Du darfst mir das, glaub ich, gar nicht verweigern,
wenn ich Homeoffice machen wollte, gell?
MURAT: Weißt du, woran mich das erinnert, wenn du das machst?
Wenn du mal früher Ding angeschaut hast:
Bei Siemens 2.000
GÜNI: Was?
MURAT: Und zwar wollte der Affe die Ameisen fressen.
Dann hat er seinen Stock genommen
und hat ihn dann in den Ameisenhaufen rein gemacht.
Dann sind die Ameisen da entlang gelaufen und dann hat er so…
So wie du jetzt gerade, weißt du?
GÜNI: Mach mal lieber sauber und sei lieber ruhig.
MURAT: Ja.
GÜNI: Du Ameisenbär, du bist ein Ameisenbär oder? [Beide lachen]
MURAT: Da hat sich mal eine wegen unseren behaarten Armen beschwert.
Weißt du das?
GÜNI: Was heißt „unseren"?
MURAT: Du bist ja auch nicht gerade…
GÜNI: Aber nicht so wie du.
Das ist ein bisschen affig.
MURAT: Man nennt dich ja auch Scary Harry. [Güni lacht]
So, jetzt drücken wir das ein bisschen lang.
[Musik]
Okay, und das tun wir jetzt in den Kühlschrank
[Mit türkischem Akzent] und dann tun wir das 1-2 Stunden kühlen.
GÜNI: Und dann?
MURAT: Ich erzähle den Leuten mal, was sie an der Uni…
MURAT: Ach so. Dann alles sauber machen.
GÜNI: Und?
MURAT: Wo ist das Kügelchen? Wo ist das Kügelchen?
Tut mir leid! Weiter geht's!
1-2 Stunden kühlen und fertig!
[Uhr]
Wir hatten ja von Anfang an diese 40 g Butterkekse übrig.
Also ihr könnt auch Oreo-Kekse oder Leibniz-Kekse nehmen.
Ihr könnt die aus dem Lidl holen.
GÜNI: Die sind sowieso nur für die Deko.
MURAT: Genau, ist nur für die Deko.
Du bist auch so ein Typ: Du bist nur für die Deko da, gell?
Aber das Problem ist, dass du nicht einmal gut aussieht.
Aber ist jetzt egal!
Auf jeden Fall nehme ich hier wieder den Gefu Speedwing 200 Pro.
Zack.
Jetzt haben wir das einmal - frittiert, wollte ich sagen - zerstört.
Jetzt machen wir Folgendes, Güni.
Und zwar gibt's jetzt einen coolen Trick.
Ich kann es nicht, weil meine Finger immer so wehtun.
Kannst du das so runterziehen, Güni?
GÜNI: Und wenn wir dieses Ding festhalten und dann wegziehen?
MURAT: Nein, das geht nicht.
Also musst es schön wegrollen.
Ich habe das in einem Video meiner Frau gesehen. Sie hat's mal gemacht.
GÜNI: Ach so.
MURAT: Mach mal!
GÜNI: Und wie soll das jetzt gehen? Man muss das doch anheben.
MURAT: Mach doch!
GÜNI: Das geht doch nicht.
MURAT: Gib mal her!
GÜNI: Das muss man doch anheben.
MURAT: Ich glaube, du hast gerade einen Schlaganfall. Kann das sein?
Hör doch auf! Was machst du gerade?
Warte kurz!
Also ehrlich, das ist aber sowas von einfach.
Aber wenn du das nicht hinkriegst, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Pass auf! Ich zeige dir, wie das der Murat macht.
Weißt du was?
Ich glaube, du hast es zerstört. Deswegen geht es gar nicht mehr.
GÜNI: [Lacht] Zeig mir mal, wie das der Murat macht!
MURAT: Los, zeig mir das mal!
Bei meiner Frau sieht das voll einfach aus.
Ich glaube, das geht auch anders.
GÜNI: Guck mal, wenn man das jetzt so festhält.
MURAT: Nein, warte!
GÜNI: Wir ziehen es hier drauf.
MURAT: Pass auf!
Ich ziehe
GÜNI: und ich halte.
MURAT: Du hältst.
Ich weiß nicht, wie meine Frau das alleine macht.
Oh, Wahnsinn, oder?
Excalibur.
Ja, ich werde der König Arthur.
Hast du gesehen, wie ich das gemacht habe?
GÜNI: Und was bist du?
MURAT: König Arthur!
GÜNI: Du bist vielleicht der König Kalle.
[Beide lachen]
MURAT: Mein Gott! Woher hast du eigentlich diese Sprüche?
Was in deinem kleinen Kopf vorgeht, möchte ich gar nicht wissen.
So, dann nehmen wir das Ding rein.
Jetzt muss ich es durchstechen.
Und dann ziehen.
Güni, du musst mir helfen.
Mein Gott, ich hätte es viel schöner machen müssen.
Egal, mach's auf! Jetzt können wir es nur noch vermiesen.
Oh mein Gott!
Oh hey, Wahnsinn!
Aber pass auf. Ich zeige noch einen coolen Trick, Güni.
GÜNI: Was machst du denn? Das musst du flacher halten.
Achtung, das fällt runter!
MURAT: So, perfekt!
So, ich schmeiße das kurz weg.
Mmh! Hammer!
So, jetzt mache ich das noch so ein bisschen gerade.
Und jetzt gibt es auch noch kleinen Trick.
Den will ich euch gerne verraten.
GÜNI: Du sollst aber nicht nach außen drücken.
MURAT: Ja, mach dir keine Gedanken, mach dir keine Gedanken.
Murat macht das!
Wenn ihr merkt, dass die Torte außen nicht schön ist,
dann macht ihr einfach mehr in die Mitte,
sodass der Fokus mehr auf die Mit fällt.
Also macht irgendetwas rein.
Mach mal kurz deine Kekse!
Wie? Kannst du das wiederholen?
Ich zeige es mal kurz, wie das geht.
Gib mal her! Pass auf!
Wenn du merkst, dass es außen nicht so schön ist…
GÜNI: Ja.
MURAT: dann musst du einfach den Fokus auf etwas anderes lenken.
Verstehst du?
Stell dir mal vor, du hast irgendeinen Mist in deinem Leben gebaut.
und sagst: Guck mal, da hinten ist ein Vogel.
Verstehst du, was ich meine?
Genau so verhält sich das, wenn du hier nochmal die Deko draufmachst.
Siehst du das?
Guck mal, da hinten ist ein Vogel.
[Beide lachen]
Man sagt im Deutsch auch Nebelfackel.
GÜNI: Ah!
MURAT: Nebelfackeln werfen - machen Sie gerne in der Politik.
Wenn sie es versaut haben, sagen sie immer „Guck mal, die anderen!"
Was auch noch cool ist:
Ihr könnt da jetzt nach eurem Geschmack draufmachen, was ihr möchtet.
Ich habe hier kandierte Macadamia-Nüsse.
Ich mag sie einfach.
Ich könnt auch noch etwas anderes drauflegen.
GÜNI: Nein, ich mag die nicht.
Probier mal! Die schmecken echt lecker.
Nein, ich bin figurbewusst.
Bei dir macht das nichts mehr aus.
MURAT: Mir kommt es so vor,
als hättest du die viel größeren Macadamia-Nüsse gegessen,
so wie es bei dir aussieht.
Dann ist es egal!
GÜNI: Iss du ruhig!
Halt du jetzt mal die Platte daneben dran.
MURAT: Nein. Pass auf, ich zeige dir, wie es geht.
Komm her, du kleiner Dummbeutel.
GÜNI: Der verreißt hier gleich den Unterboden.
Guck, wie er den Boden verreißt.
Warum hörst du nicht auf mich? Warum?
MURAT: Jetzt sind wir soweit. Jetzt lassen wir hier jemanden probieren,
der unparteiisch ist.
Okay? Eine Person, die immer die Wahrheit sagt.
und uns nie anlügt - genau!
Und zwar holen wir die Jutta.
Diesmal holen wir die Jutta.
Liebe Jutta, kommst du zu uns?
JUTTA: Jawoll!
Na Jungs, hat das alles geklappt?
MURAT: Bei mir schon, bei ihm nicht!
JUTTA: Wie schaut's aus?
GÜNI: Bist du nicht zufrieden?
MURAT: Sieht cool aus!
JUTTA: Das sieht jetzt erst einmal gut aus.
GÜNI: Das ist ein Männerkuchen. [Murat stimmt zu]
JUTTA: Er ist rustikal, würd ich sagen.
MURAT: Also probier mal, Jutta!
Womit schneiden wir an?
JUTTA: Mit einem Messer, würde ich sagen. [Murat stimmt zu]
GÜNI: „Womit schneiden wir an?" [Lacht]
Es macht mich so kaputt.
Los.
MURAT: Und zwar hier zur Erklärung.
Das ist ein Lemon Blueberry Pie Keks…
GÜNI: Was? Pie?
MURAT: Kuchen…
JUTTA: Okay.
MURAT: Aber wenn er nicht schmeckt, dann sag es bitte einfach, okay?
Kannst du ruhig ehrlich sagen!
JUTTA: Achtung! Ich brauche eine…
Ah, du nimmst die Winkelpalette.
MURAT: Ja, ich nehme die Winkelpalette.
JUTTA: Okay.
MURAT: Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich hätte den Kuchen vielleicht
noch ein bisschen länger kühlen lassen müssen.
So. Oh!
[Güni lacht]
JUTTA: Komm, wir nehmen noch eine…
MURAT: Lass mal dem Günni auch noch ein Stückchen!
Obwohl er es eigentlich nicht verdient hat.
JUTTA: Hat er es nicht verdient? [Murat verneint]
GÜNI: Aber langsam!
JUTTA: Warst du nicht fleißig?
MURAT: Er hat mich den ganzen Tag nur beleidigt.
GÜNI: Er hält den Teller schräg.
Er hat überhaupt kein Gefühl.
JUTTA: Oh!
GÜNI: Deine Macadamia-Nüsse!
JUTTA: Gabeln!
[Güni lacht] Was machst du denn?
Nüsse dazu? [Murat bejaht]
GÜNI: Normal ist anders.
JUTTA: Komm, wir probieren!
GÜNI: Zum Wohl!
JUTTA: Zum Wohl!
Aber sieht gut aus. Sieht echt gut aus.
MURAT: Frisch, gell? [Jutta stimmt zu]
JUTTA: Ist da Zitrone drin?
GÜNI: Ja, Schale und Saft.
MURAT: Weißt du, wie das eigentlich schmeckt?
Kennst du den Joghurt mit der Ecke?
Da gab es 2 Ecken: eine kleine Ecke und eine große Ecke.
Und Güni war immer der, der die große Ecke in die kleine reingetan hat.
So! Das warst doch du, gell?
JUTTA: Jetzt mal zurück zum Kuchen.
Wenn der noch ein bisschen länger gekühlte hätte,
wäre der richtig, richtig perfekt!
GÜNI: Wir haben nunmal keine Zeit, gell?
MURAT: Weil er so hetzt. [Güni lacht]
Ja, er hetzt.
JUTTA: Müsst ihr heute nochmal was auf dem Bau schaffen?
GÜNI: Nein, ich kann gleich nach Hause gehen und werde vollbezahlt.
MURAT: Er ist ein Hetzer, ein Gutbürger.
JUTTA: Noch einmal zurück.
Diese Schicht hier: Was war das?
MURAT: Keine Ahnung, was das ist. [Jutta und Güni lachen]
GÜNI: Das wissen wir doch nicht mehr!
JUTTA: Güni, was habt ihr hier gemacht? Was war das?
GÜNI: Das war wie Pudding.
So ähnlich. Das war wie Quark.
JUTTA: Quark? Nein, Quark ist hier drin.
GÜNI: Das ist doch mir egal.
MURAT: Das ist doch Pudding gewesen. Mein Gott!
GÜNI: Jutta, iss doch einfach!
MURAT: Aber es ist lecker.
Jutta, tu uns einen Gefallen:
Stell uns nicht so viele Fragen! Wir haben nicht so viele Antworten.
JUTTA: Aber es ist wirklich lecker. Echt zart!
MURAT: Nicht so süß, gell? Also nicht so mächtig.
Das einzige, was hier mächtig ist, ist sein…
JUTTA: Ja gut, ihr seid beide jetzt nicht gerade…
GÜNI: Aha!
MURAT: Guck dir das mal an!
JUTTA: Er ist auch viel größer als du.
Guck mal!
GÜNI: Jutta, kennst du den japanischen Kugelfisch? Kennst du den?
JUTTA: Ja, den kenne ich. [Güni und Jutta lachen]
Und? Was willst du mir damit sagen?
GÜNI: Nein, ich meine nur. Ich wollte nur wissen, ob du den Fisch kennst.
JUTTA: Ja.
MURAT: Vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen.
Lasst uns einen Daumen da, nach oben natürlich.
Nach unten für den Güni.
Ihr könnt gern kommentieren.
Ich könnt Güni auch beleidigen.
Hatet die anderen. Hatet nicht uns.
Und abonniert den Kanal, auch wenn er nicht unser Kanal ist.
Ja?
Vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen!
JUTTA: Tschüss!
MURAT: Macht's gut.
JUTTA: Kommt, raus aus der Küche!
Abspülen, aufräumen.
MURAT: Helft mir! Helft mir doch!
[Musik]